de telles tragédies dans la vie oblige à
la vérité
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission décrypteront comme
chaque fois du lundi au mercredi à cette
semaine l'essentiel de l'information
avec nos invités et nos reporters sur le
terrain tout de suite les grands titres
de l'actualité de ce mardi 29 décembre
[Musique]
der confinement locaux sur le territoire
ce n'est pas exclu une piste étudiée ce
matin en conseil de défense présidée par
emmanuel macron c'est ce que réclame des
élus locaux un pied du robot épidémique
dans leur région comme le dans le grand
est
le conseil scientifique juge lui
probable une reprise incontrôlée il est
aussi question ce matin de la campagne
de vaccination qui a débuté dimanche
dans les ehpad problème elle la défiance
des français y compris des personnels
soignants face au vaccin
kaiser biotech
[Musique]
bruxelles demande à pékin la libération
d'une journaliste chinoise est de 12
militants hong kong et un appel qui
intervient alors qu'un important d'
accord sino européen sur la protection
des investissements est sur le point
d'aboutir
le fruit de sept années de négociation
nous verrons si le projet et menacé son
[Musique]
attention les négociations post break
sites ne sont pas encore tout à fait
terminée un autre casse-tête gibraltar
la ministre espagnole des affaires
étrangères a lancé hier un ultimatum au
royaume-uni 72 heures pour éviter le
rétablissement d'une frontière dure
entre l'espagne et lanclas britannique
le rocher craint d'être isolé sans libre
circulation
reconfirme en locaux ou pas que va
décider manial mâcon face au rebond
inquiétant de l'épidémie notamment dans
le grand est le chef de l'état a présidé
ce matin un énième conseil de défense
sanitaire à deux jours du nouvel an le
nouvel an une période propice à la
circulation plus active du virus
pour l'instant rien n'est sûr rien n'a
filtré des échanges de ce matin le chef
de l'état s'exprimera publiquement au
plus tard jeudi pour les traditionnels
voeux du nouvel an mais pas sûr qu'il
annonce de nouvelles mesures sanitaires
plusieurs territoires inquiète
aujourd'hui la région grand est la
bourgogne franche comté le département
des alpes maritimes de nombreux élus
plaident pour des reconfirmant locaux
comme les maires de nancy colmar et
reims et on fait le point tout de suite
avec alexis poulain c'est notre rubrique
l'édito fort bonsoir alexis poulain
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur
arte france conseil de défense donc
olive et veyran s'exprime sur france 2
ce soir
la semaine prochaine il y aura un autre
conseil de défense sanitaire le
gouvernement on voit qu'il est au
travail à l'offensive
il se donne cette image est au travail
on a surtout l'impression d'un
gouvernement perdu dans cette crise qui
perdure avec des conseils de défense sur
conseil de défense c'est toujours à peu
près le même scénario un conseil de
défense le matin tout ça est bien sûr
privé autour des vrais de mâcon qui
décide
entouré de quelques personnalités
choisies et puis un membre de l'exécutif
par le soir pour expliquer aux français
ce qui a été décidé en privé le matin
autour d'une table aujourd'hui c'est
olivier ferrand qui s'y colle parfois
c'est jean castex parfois c'est emmanuel
macron mais les voeux arrive entre les
deux conseils de défense celui de cette
semaine est celui de la semaine
prochaine donc ce soir c'est la
politesse alors via olivier ferrand qui
va sans doute annoncer est bien de faire
attention pour le jour de l'an pas de
nouvelles mesures puisque on attendra le
conseil de défense de la semaine
prochaine sans doute une campagne bien
sûr de vaccination qui commence très
doucement donc sans doute l'a expliqué
pourquoi qu'est ce qui se passe qu'est
ce qui est prévu dans les jours qui
viennent et toujours peut-être cette
question d'art confinement locales cette
fois ci puisque certaines régions
dont le grand est ont du mal apparemment
à baisser les chiffres de contamination
et ça ne va pas aider avec de nombreux
touristes britanniques et autres qui
sont repartis de suisse dans la nuit
en disparaissant souhaitant porter ou
non du virus mais on ne sait pas avec ce
virus mutant qui qui visiblement est
plus agressif en termes de contamination
que lors l'ancien qu'ovide 19 tel qu'il
était lors de la première vague
donc c'est à peu près toujours la même
chose on s'y est habitué
on va peut-être aussi demandé plus de
clarté plus de transparence sur cette
campagne de vaccination ait plus de
clarté sur cattan finalement le
gouvernement pour mettre sur la table un
plan clair et arrêté d'improviser de
semaine en semaine
donc pas suffisamment de clarté selon
vous du côté de du gouvernement dans le
cadre de sa stratégie et de lutte contre
le coc vie de dix neuf jusqu'ici est ce
que vous c'est pas un peu sévère tout de
même je crois pas que c'est sévère si on
regarde cette équipe qui est en charge
depuis le mois de mars tout est à la
fois à fonction contradictoires tout est
parfois mensonges et tout et dire tout
et son contraire rappelez-vous début
mars et noël mâcon et son épouse
brigitte aller au théâtre et nous disait
que ce virus ne devait pas nous arrêter
de vivre
bon et bien les théâtres ne sont pas
prêts de rouvrir pas plus que les
cinémas il y a eu ensuite le fiasco des
masques c'est tout de même incroyable de
voir tous les responsables et porte
parole de la majorité qui se gaussait
sur les plateaux de télévision d'autres
les masques ne servait à rien que
c'était ridicule qu'enfin on n'en avait
pas besoin
jérôme salomon qui avait menti qui avait
voulu cacher son mensonge lorsqu'à un
rapport du sénat l'avait pointé du doigt
il avait lui-même choisi de ne pas
renouveler le stock stratégique lumière
jérôme salomon il n'a pas été
démissionné il n'a pas démissionné il a
toujours toute la confiance de ce
gouvernement et du président de la
république il est là donc qu'attendre de
cette équipe qui a à la fois raté le
premier confinement puisque nous voilà
reconfirmer une deuxième fois et
peut-être une troisième fois localement
ou pas qui a raté les masques et les
commandes de masques qui sont arrivées
bien en retard et beaucoup de soignants
en ont souffert certains en sont morts
puisqu'il manquait de matériel et qui a
raté les tests la phase de test puisque
nous n'avons pas eu une phase de test
non plus à la
hauteur de ce qui était attendu et là
nous voilà dans la phase vaccination
avec la même équipe qui est là depuis
récompensé pour sa médiocrité
qu'attendre si ce n'est un fiasco de
plus je crois que on a vu les chiffres
de ce week end
moins d'une centaine de personnes
vaccinées dans les ehpad en france c'est
lui entre 10000 et 20000 selon les
sources qui ont été vaccinées en
allemagne on est très loin en france
tout le monde nous regardons mais qu'est
ce qu'il se passait ce que c'est un
problème de logistique est ce que c'est
un problème de chaîne du froid est ce
que c'est tout simplement parce que
encore une fois on n'a rien préparé
alain fischer monsieur vaccin est
totalement inaudible invisible c'est le
monsieur invisible de cette campagne de
vaccination il a parlé une fois sur une
radio pour dire que tout allait bien
c'était normal de commencer doucement
oui dit que c'est normal de commencer
doucement mais est ce qu'on a à votre
avis est-ce qu'on est suffisamment armé
ce qu'on a suffisamment de doses pour
mener cette campagne de vaccination dans
les meilleures conditions et l'élargir
surtout alors c'est là que ça va devenir
intéressant puisque nous avons décidé de
commenter massivement au niveau européen
à la fois pour la mise sur le marché de
ces vaccins celle autorités de santé
européennes qui décide la même autorité
de santé qui avait décidé de mettre leur
md et vire sur le marché médicaments
dangereux pour les malades du code vide
mais tout ça grâce à la pression des
lobbys comme celui de gilead et bien
voilà que nous avons commandé les
vaccins au niveau européen et nous
allons voir si nous avons suffisamment
de doses tout simplement
aujourd'hui plusieurs candidats vaccins
arrivent sur le marché seulement seither
et biotech le vaccin arn semble être
capable de répondre à la demande
astrazeneca a pris beaucoup de retard
l'institut pasteur a pris beaucoup de
retard
visiblement l'europe ne veut pas
entendre parler de vaccins russe ou
venant d'ailleurs donc c'est priseur qui
fait un jackpot avec ursula von der
leyen qui vient de déclarer que l'union
européenne allait commander 300 millions
de doses de plus de ce vaccin parce que
voilà les autres vaccins n'arrive pas or
nous avons le docteur swaminathan qui
est quand même la chef médical de l'om
est l'organisation mondiale de la santé
qui nous dit que sur ce vaccin et les
autres vaccins d'ailleurs candidat
rien ne nous prouve aujourd'hui que ces
vaccins empêche d'attraper la maladie et
de la transmettre
et certains veulent parler de passeports
vaccinale pour passer d'un pays à
l'autre mais être vaccinés ne veut pas
dire que vous ne pouvez pas transmettre
la maladie aujourd'hui c'est l' oms même
qu'il le dit donc au delà même d'avoir
les doses
reste à savoir si ces stratégies
vaccinales va porter ses fruits et si
nous verrons bien
quelque chose se passait mais clairement
aujourd'hui voir qu'en france nous
prenons un tel retard alors que le
vaccin est censé être l'alpha et l'oméga
du déconfinement et de la reprise
économique
c'est inquiétant et politiquement ça
peut être un coup fatal pour emmanuel
macron même si certains sondages comme
d'habitude le donne à ces eaux
ça me paraît quand même assez cocasse
parce que là on commence à se poser
beaucoup de questions depuis mars
tout est mensonge manipulation pas
vraiment de transparence et ratages
alors est-ce que la vaccination sera pas
ratage de plus 2020 terre nous le dira
mais aujourd'hui l' oms reste très
prudente quant à la suite des opérations
en tout cas sur cette question des durs
consignes mans locales dans certaines
régions le gouvernement refuse pour
l'instant de deux statues et olivier
verront s'exprime en ce moment sur
l'antenne de france 2 il affirme que la
date butoir du 7 janvier fixée par le
premier ministre en tout cas c'est une
date donc pour laquelle il sera
difficile de lever la totalité des
contraintes c'est ce qu'il affirme et
apparemment il n'envisage pas non plus
d'heureux confinement locaux comme le
demande la plupart à beaucoup d'élus ben
voilà on va continuer à être confiné on
va continuer à sacrifier les petits
commerces des le secteur de la culture
qui je pense maintenant on attend plus
de réouvrir les restaurateurs qui même
s'ils ont reçu des aides savent très
bien que ces aides vont toucher à leur
fin et qu'il faudra rembourser les
dettes
voilà où nous en sommes parce que
stratégie vaccinale mal organisé où sont
les 50 super congélateur une entreprise
française près de lyon un produit des
supers congélateur elle a dit
notamment récemment dans un article que
le gouvernement français n'avait passé
aucune commande auprès d'elle pour des
super congélateur la chaîne du froid va
t elle être respectée aurons-nous
suffisamment de doses est déjà
aujourd'hui sur les doses on ne va
vacciner que les personnes les plus
fragiles donc dans les ehpad et et
certains soignants déjà là on n'a pas
tous les soignants et puis un autre
problème important problème ou donner à
voir les français sont extrêmement
sceptique par rapport à ce nouveau
vaccin
on est les champions du monde en fait 40
% seulement de la population qui
souhaitent se faire vacciner
c'est très très peu hélas comme il n'y a
pas vraiment d'exemple donné d'en haut
ni emmanuel macron ni les membres du
gouvernement ni personne finalement
essaye de faire une vraie campagne de
promotion de cette vaccination
peut-être de peur parce que l'opinion
publique n'y est pas prête et ce qui
s'était passé avec le h1n1
je crois qu'en france on a quand même le
souvenir de nombreux scandales
sanitaires que ce soit le sang contaminé
que ce soit le problème
donc voilà on va parler de cette
défiance d'ailleurs vis-à-vis du vaccin
ça concerne pas seulement les français
mais je le rappelle donc olivier ferrand
s'exprime sur france 2 actuellement il
annonce que ce n'est pas certain que la
totalité des contraintes soient levés au
7 janvier par ailleurs il se pourrait
qu'il ya un couvre-feu à 18h envisagée à
partir du 2 janvier dans certains
départements merci à vous alexis poulain
le gouvernement sur le fond donc de
cette stratégie sanitaire et de la
campagne de vaccination alors qu'on
parle déjà d'une troisième vague
épidémique on le rappelle depuis
dimanche on vaccine dans les ehpad il
s'agit de la première phase et sur les
deux premières journées une cinquantaine
de personnes ont été vaccinées
problème la défiance des français on en
parlait face au vaccin finder gentex est
des chances a grandi compris parmi elles
et personnel soignant
illustration dans les ehpad selon un
sondage interne réalisée début décembre
par la fédération des établissements
hospitaliers et des aides à la personne
seules 19% de ses professionnels
souhaitent se faire vacciner une
défiance qui pourrait être influencé les
pensionnaires de cv
glissement et dans une tribune du jdd
daniel guillerme le président de la
fédération nationale des infirmiers et
co initiateur de la campagne ensemble
prévention qu'ovide propose de rendre la
vaccination obligatoire pour le
personnel soignant et c'est justement
l'objet de notre face à face ce soir
[Musique]
pour en débattre nous sommes avec
bertrand legrand médecins généralistes
attiré amouroux porte-parole du syndicat
infirmier sm pays syndicat national des
professionnels infirmiers
bonsoir à vous merci d'être avec nous ce
soir sur arte france
alors évidemment cette question ce soir
est ce qu'il faut rendre la vaccination
obligatoire pour les personnels
soignants
vous êtes d'accord ou pas bertrand
legrand la rendre obligatoire
pourquoi pas enfin c'est en fait je
ferai des jeunes voulait permettre tout
simplement puisque aujourd'hui par
exemple moi qui souhaiteraient même
vacciné au plus vite
on ne me donne pas la possibilité de le
faire donc moi la question que j'ai
envie de vous poser ces cas le patient
qui n'a pas envie de se faire vacciner
et qui est prêt à me donner sa dose
c'est à dire quand vous dites que pour
l'instant ce n'est pas possible de se
faire vacciner
elle a pour l'instant on a décidé de
priorité et on n'a pas décidé qu'il y
avait du personnel qui méritait d'être
vaccinés prioritairement moi je suis
parfaitement scandalisé que les
personnels politiques
or en partant du président mais aussi du
premier ministre ne sera pas vacciner
prioritairement c'est pas un passe-droit
c'est clairement nécessité si jamais
demain nos ingénieurs du nucléaire
tomber tous manade et qu'on se retrouver
avec des centrales nucléaires en
perdition ce serait catastrophique donc
il est hors de question de ne pas
prioriser la part est la biac six
nations en fonction de ce que les
personnels apporte à la france et je
pense que c'est ainsi que comme ça les
français comprendront que lise ya un
vrai intérêt stratégique à se vacciner
thierry amouroux vous êtes opposé cette
vaccination obligatoire pour les
personnels soignants qu'il n'était pour
l'instant pas envisagée par a
le gouvernement oui on pense que l'on
doit rester dans la même logique que la
vaccination contre la grippe ont pour
noms pour l'instant on manque de de
données suis anti g un retour sont un
peu bizarre je vais vous m'entendez
ouais on vous entend vous entend
poursuivre et d'accord donc au niveau
des données
il nous manque deux choses importantes
d'une part si on sait effectivement
qu'il ya la vaccination est très
efficace pour éviter les faits graves de
la maladie
à titre individuel par contre nous
n'avons pas de données sur la capacité
du vaccin à empêcher la transmission et
en particulier une fois que l'on est
vaccinée on peut être porteurs
asymptomatiques en ayant été virus dans
toute la sphère orl et donc rester
contaminants or l'intérêt de la
vaccination des professionnels de santé
n'est pas pour eux-mêmes parce qu'ils
sont le reflet de la population générale
mais avant tout une validation à lettres
une liste pour empêcher leurs patients
fragiles d'être contaminés s'il n'y a
pas des faits avérés
ça va poser un souci le vaccin ferries
heures n'a pas de donné là dessus et au
niveau du moderna les données qui sont
sortis et c'est qu'on était contagieux
entre les deux injections
il n'y a pas eu d'autres d'autres
données ensuite
donc ça c'est un problème premier
problème le deuxième souci c'est que
nous sommes un certain nombre à avoir
déjà été le contaminer par le coe j
lors de la première de la seconde vague
et donc nous avons des anticorps et à ce
stade
18 décembre la chaîne a estimé que
n'avait pas lieu vacciner les personnes
et qui avait déjà eu locaux vides
donc voilà on a ces deux problèmes à
résoudre alors on a une chance vous
parliez de la lenteur française ça va
nous permettre de voir ce qui se passe
au niveau des états unis où il ya deux
millions de vaccinés les anglais où il
ya eu 800 mille accidents
on va avoir plus de données et avoir les
réponses à nos questions
mais bertrand legrand sur cet argument
justement de la transmission du virus
pour lequel visiblement le le vaccin ne
ne ne peux rien faire
est ce que c'est un argument qui est qui
tient la route selon vous alors il ya
deux choses la première chose c'est que
une étude sur la contagiosité post
vaccinales ne peut avoir lieu qu'après
un certain délai et c'est ce qu'on a vu
par ailleurs dans d'autres vaccins
donc quand vous dites on n'a pas prouvé
bien sûr on n'a pas prouvé
et alors bien sûr qu'on n'a pas prouvé
je vois pas où est le problème
et je comprends pas où on veut faire
monter la sauce et la mayonnaise
évidemment qu'on n'a pas prouvé
puisqu'on n'a pas le temps nécessaire
pour permettre de prouver cela donc ça
c'est une chose qui était imparable pour
tout le monde donc tout les complotistes
on s'amusait à jouer sur 7 sur cet
argument
deuxième chose je voudrais vous rappelez
vous êtes infirmier
j'imagine que vous portez un masque
quand vous voyez vos patients - j'en ai
mien avant même qu'on me demande de le
mettre
donc la protection des patients elle
passe par la protection physique
le fait que je sois vacciner ne va pas
me faire libérer mais protection
physique
donc il n'y a aucun argument là dedans à
ne pas se vacciner la réalité c'est que
le vaccin oms et protège des formes
graves
les formes graves tous les gens qui
prennent une dose maximum et vos
infirmiers prennent une dose maximum
parce qu'ils sont au contact du patient
c'est la raison pour laquelle j'ai évité
à chaque fois pendant mais mon travail
d'envoyer des infirmiers dans le
domicile des patients qui est une bombe
le viral j'ai pas envie qu'ils y aillent
sans protection donc moi personnellement
je suis désolé de vous le dire mais sur
la base des études scientifiques qui ont
été sortis du kaiser
depuis maintenant au moins deux semaines
puisque j'avais fait une interview avec
vous il n'ya pas longtemps et je n'ai
pas les données maintenant qu'on allait
donner
c'est quand même assez évident que 1 le
vaccin ne présente quasiment aucun effet
secondaire voire moins que le placebo
c'est quand même assez assez
impressionnant et qu'il est
particulièrement efficace pour éviter
les formes graves
bien sûr sur la contamination on va
devoir garder le masque au moins jusqu'à
ce qu'on ait soit au mois de juillet ou
au mois 2 août pour avoir le recul
nécessaire
thierry amouroux peut-être parce que je
pense qu'il n'a pas l'air d'apprécier
qu'on parle de complotisme oui bon ça
assez incroyable comme comme argument au
moins en tant que professionnels de
santé on applique que tous les vaccins
obligatoires
on se vaccine majoritairement contre la
grippe ou protéger l'innovation fragile
mais entre les complotistes et les
j'accepte tous des injections par des
injonctions gouvernementales
il ya une limite normal voilà nous on se
base sur des données scientifiques pour
l'instant on a constaté ces données
voilà c'est tout mauvais le fait que ça
n'agissent pas sur la transmission n'est
pas de données sur l'action sur la
transmission c'est un fait objectif est
sûre le moderna on a vu que des gens qui
était séronégatif qui se sont fait
vacciner se sont retrouvés avec une pcr
positive voilà thierry amouroux juste et
on voit que c'est quand même étonnant de
voir que les professionnels de santé se
montrent réticents à se faire vacciner
et dans le même temps ils ont un peu
aussi on peut l'imaginer l'obligation
d'encourager à les français assez
vacciner moi personnellement si mon
médecin me dit je vais pas me faire
vacciner
je vais me poser des questions alors que
me dit de le faire moi j'aime poser des
questions en sortant du cabinet
attention on parle de la vaccination des
professionnels de santé qui sont le
reflet il ya un lien
excusez moi mais pour tous résidents en
ehpad
il est évident que il faut se faire
vacciner des possibles et la stratégie
grade b de la hs est très bien pour ça
parce que le risque de mourir d'une
forme grave du duc au vide est très
important par rapport aux effets
possibles l'éventuelle mandat taxe un
après et c'est comme pour tout la
vaccination comptes annuels contre la
grippe elle est ciblée sur les personnes
les plus fragiles les personnes âgées
les personnes atteintes de maladies
chroniques etc
voilà on est toujours dans du bénéfice
risque
et après s'il n'y a pas d'action sur la
transmission que les soignants vaccinés
seront toujours contaminants ben voilà
il ya ces les limites de la vaccination
a twist alors que lorsqu'on est vaccinée
contre la grippe on est patente amis
n'ont alors plus que vous parlez du
bénéfice risque
il ya beaucoup de de personnel soignant
de médecins qui met en avant justement
ce ratio bertrand legrand pour
convaincre justement elle les français à
se faire vacciner aussi ça c'est un
argument aussi quelle équipe peut
compter
je peux pas laisser dire que la
vaccination n'a qu'un rôle altruiste
c'est complètement faux la première
mesure que vous pouvez voir de tous les
tous les jours c'est la vaccination pour
le tétanos vous vacciner que pour vous
même le tétanos n'est pas transmissible
en interhumains donc la vaccination elle
a pour premier objectif le bénéfice
individuel
il est évident que tout professionnel de
santé a tout intérêt à se protéger
contre le coronavirus on a payé un lourd
tribut et j'ai pas envie de voir
d'autres personnes payées un des
attributs supplémentaires parce qu'on
tergiverse pendant 2 3 mois et la
deuxième chose c'est que lui le bénéfice
pour la population en général est
important et il ne se peut se mesurer
qu'à un an deux ans donc forcément on en
aura pas ces données là donc soit on
fait ce qu'on a fait l'extrait premier
de la classe et on va se planter parce
que sans vaccination
par jour franchement ça se mérite
vraiment de se poser la question de
savoir si on a des vaccins ou pas mais
on peut attendre on peut encore attendre
il y aura des morts en plus fins et
complètement stupide donc les vraies
études ont été publiées
la pharmacocinétique a été publié on
sait comment agit de vaccins on sait
qu'elle a été la niveau de révolution
ces vaccins arn sont une véritable
révolution
les anglais ont pris la mesure des
choses avant nous alors même que l'on
n'avait pas les études je me demande
bien d'ailleurs comment ils ont fait
mais ils ont fait le bon pari et nous on
a fait le mauvais pari et on va
maintenant justifier cette pénurie en
faisant croire qu'il ya une raison pour
laquelle on vaccine trop lentement
c'est une grosse blague enfin n'importe
qui peut vacciner les infirmiers comme
les médecins
ça n'a absolument aucune difficulté
d'injecter c'est notre coeur de métier
et à nous mettre des barrières
administratives et à nous empêcher de
faire la vaccination
il n'y a qu'une seule raison c'est que
le vaccin n'est pas disponible ou n'est
pas livrables
justement est ce qu'il faut en arriver à
ce point là rendre la vaccination
obligatoire pour les personnels
soignants je reviens donc à cette
première question dans dans le même
temps c'est vrai que on se dit aussi que
vu la défiance des français vis à vis du
gouvernement et les français qui sont
très attachés à leur personnel soignant
on l'a vu durant toute cette crise
sanitaire finalement il ya aussi
peut-être un devoir d'exemplarité me
rendront la disponible et je pense que
le problème sera réglé ça sert à rien de
spéculer permettez moi de me vacciner
permettait à chaque infirmier à chaque
pharmacien à chaque enfin tout personnel
soignant de se vacciner vous verrez
qu'ils le feront personne n'a envie de
perdre le goût l'odorat ou je suis
retrouvé en réanimation donc évidemment
que pour le bénéfice individuel nous
allons le faire c'est une évidence
non mais il ya quand même une réticence
est un parmi les les personnels
soignants les infirmiers et un tiers et
amour ou encore une fois il ya aussi le
fait que nous sommes nombreux à avoir
été déjà contaminé et donc nous avons
les anticorps voilà est par contre les
études
qui ont été faites jusqu'à présent et
exclut et les gens qui étaient déjà
porteur du coc vide est exclu et les
femmes enceintes expliquer les
immunodéprimés
donc du coup mais il ya un certain
nombre de trous dans les techniques et
on sait pas ce qu'il en est pour
quelqu'un qui a des anticorps du duc au
vide de s'injecter le vaccin juste un
dernier mot pour conclure parce que je
le disais au début de cette émission
différent il s'est exprimé chez nos
confrères de france 2 la parler de cette
campagne de vaccination l'a dit que
c'était normal qu'on avance lentement
peut-être plus lentement coco nos
voisins et que son retard il sera à
rattraper courant janvier
qu'en pensez vous bah c'est bien ça
permet profiter justement du rheu qu'on
va à sur les américains et les anglais
il ya un certain nombre de réticences
parce que l'on sait que les choses ont
été fait rapidement
jova les axes 1 de la population
générale les les quatre autres façons
prévu que à partir du printemps
donc là on aura suffisamment de recul
sur des millions de personnes et donc du
coup je pense qu'un certain nombre de
réticences vont vont tomber d'elle-même
la verna le grand bâtiment
merci bernard legrand a tous rapidement
bon c'est tout simple chaque retard ce
pèlerin au nombre de vies et en prix de
confinement je pensais que c'était
vachement important de ne pas se
confiner et que l'économie prime et
surtout je comprends pas de ne pas avoir
aujourd'hui d'entrepreneurs qui nous
pousse à vacciner la population pour
éviter de fermer leur entreprise
mais manifestement c'est plus le
problème du jour merci à vous deux merci
bertrand legrand médecin généraliste est
tirée à mauroux porte-parole du syndicat
infirmier fm pays syndicat national des
professionnels infirmiers siens et dans
quelques instants nous parlerons de
l'accord de protection réciproque des
investissements entre pékin
et bruxelles qui pourrait bien aboutir
après plus de sept années de
négociations puis direction gibraltar
dont le destin est lié aux briques site
la ministre espagnole des affaires
étrangères a donné hier 72 heures au
royaume uni pour éviter le
rétablissement d'une frontière dure
entre l'espagne et l'enclavé britannique
restait avec mon sur rt france
[Musique]
des organes d'un flux ans de propagande
et de propagande mensongère pour usa
today
[Musique]
alors non mais vous êtes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous insistez beaucoup sur l'aspect des
dépenses publiques ce que je critique
c'est que on est dans un état
d'addiction de grande dépendance à la
dépense publique je ne veux pas du sang
et des larmes leçon il est là mon les
actes et je dépense trop d'état je pense
en tout cas qu'il ya trop de
bureaucratie c'est à dire un état
inefficace tout ça a été financée
essentiellement par de la dette
le problème est moins la dette en
réalité moi je pense qu'on remboursera
la dette par la croissance donc il faut
essayer de libérer l'économie française
et notamment le travail
notre problème en france c'est un
problème où la dépense publique est
excessive
mais surtout elle n'est pas productive
les français n'en ont pas pour leur
argent
de ce point de vue emmanuel macron n'a
rien changé par exemple par rapport à
son prédécesseur françois hollande
[Musique]
m
on est bons soirs bienvenue sur rt
france si vous nous rejoignez 20h30
heure française après sept ans de
négociations le projet d'accord sur la
protection des investissements entre la
chine et l'union européenne est sur le
point d'aboutir
la dernière version de l'accord a été
présenté hier aux représentants des 27
une mouture qui semble faire l'unanimité
mais bruxelles réclame la libération de
12 hong kong et arrêtés en mer l'union
européenne réclament aussi la libération
immédiate de la journaliste citoyenne
zong tyan condamné hier à quatre ans de
prison voit cela avec florian lambert
c'est une déclaration qui représente un
grand pas dans un dossier ouvert depuis
sept ans grâce au travail acharné des
deux parties nous avons continué à
réaliser des progrès importants lors des
dernières négociations et l'avenir est
très prometteur
nous espérons que cet accord pourra se
concrétiser rapidement car il va fournir
un cadre général garantissant la
coopération commerciale entre la chine
et l'ue eux et offrir de réels avantages
aux entreprises et aux citoyens des deux
partis proches d'un compromis sur la
protection réciproque de leurs
investissements la chine et les 27 états
membres de l'union européenne semble
enfin s'être mis d'accord après que
pékin aurait accepté de revoir sa
position sur le travail forcé d'après
les sources diplomatiques
mais de quoi s'agit-il concrètement
c'est un texte visant à garantir les
conditions d'activité les entrepreneurs
lorsqu'ils investissent en europe ou en
chine
à noter qu'il ne s'agit pas d'un accord
de libre échange sur les transactions
commerciales
quel effet dans l'avenir des effets
considérables
l'union européenne et la chine sont l'un
pour l'autre les partenaires commerciaux
les plus importants
chacun devant les états unis quand le
stock d'investissements de l'union
européenne vers la chine s'élève à 150
milliards d'euros celui de letat chinois
vers l'union européenne atteint 113
milliards d'euros quel intérêt pour
l'union européenne
l'intérêt de protéger les entreprises
européennes implantées en chine
le texte est censé garantir le respect
de la propriété intellectuelle des
entreprises européennes
interdire les transferts de technologie
forcé et imposer des règles de
transparence sur les subventions versées
aux entreprises publiques chinoises
bruxelles souhaite aussi je cite que la
chine un signe l'ensemble des huit
conventions fondamentales de
l'organisation internationale du travail
pour l'heure pékin n'en a ratifié que
quatre quel intérêt pour la chine depuis
que le groupe chinois huawei a été exclu
du marché des équipements pour la 5g
dans de nombreux pays d'europe
pékin veut des garanties d'accès aux
marchés publics européens
et maintenant si la chine valide cet
accord le parlement européen devra
également le ratifier or quelques points
de discorde existe toujours entre les
deux géants économiques
le dernier en date la demande de
libération immédiate formulées par
l'union européennes de la journaliste
citoyenne exane condamné ce lundi à
quatre ans de prison pour avoir diffusé
des vidéos sur wii one la ville qui a
été l'épicentre de la pandémie due
coronavirus reste à savoir quel effet
aura cette nouvelle controverse sur les
discussions en cours entre la chine et
l'union européenne
justement on en parle à tout de suite
avec jean vincent brisset lé directeur
de recherche à l'iris spécialiste de la
chine bonsoir à vous jean vincent
brisset merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france d'abord en quoi consiste cet
accord un sino européen sur la
protection des investissements
alors oui il ya une phase théorique dans
cet accord normalement à l'issue de cet
accord les investissements de chaque
pays dans chaque région dans l'autre
devrait protéger protéger audio et leur
propriété intellectuelle au niveau des
transferts de technologie et au niveau
purement matérielle de la réalité des
investissements
je sais pas exactement ce que ça va
donner
c'est un accord extrêmement complexe il
a fallu sept ans pour en arriver là et
ça doit se traduire par des milliers de
pages de documentation
un clic sur pas encore été étudiée
profondément on parle d'un accord
stratégique pourquoi et quelles sont les
secteurs concernés
tous les secteurs sont concernés sachant
que l'europe n'a toujours pas abolir les
transfère le pouvoir servir à la défense
chinoise à l'armement chinois
1 les sanctions sont toujours en cours
après tiananmen elles sont copieusement
violée par tous les partenaires
européens et la chine pour contourner
ces sanctions utilise que la paix new
tunes yuming c'était pour le peuple pour
l'armée toutes les tout ce qu'elle peut
récupérer à titre civil est utilisé dans
le domaine militaire est utilisé donc
tout ça ce sont des choses qui sont
réels qui sont extrêmement gênantes et
qui n'apparaissent pas au des plans dans
cet accord c'est ans de négociations ce
n'est pas rien quand même comment
expliquer selon timing au départ je
pense que les négociateurs européens
pensaient que la chine allait
fonctionner ce métro à tout comme tous
les tous les pays du monde à faire tout
ce qui est prévu dans l' omc et ont
découvert que la chine a pas envie de
respecter les règles de l'om sait n a
pas envie de devenir un pays normal dans
tous les domaines et en particulier dans
le domaine des échanges économiques et
donc elle a à chaque fois il a fallu
obtenir des promesses dont on ne sait
toujours pas si elles seront obtenus
parce qu'on a été souvent quand même
échaudés on passait on voit tout de même
que l'union européenne abandonne passer
cette vieille habitude de poser des
conditionnalités
cette fois encore c'est le cas sur les
droits de l'homme elle nous y habituer
elle réclame la libération immédiate
d'une journaliste qui a enquêté sur la
crise sanitaire en chine et plusieurs
aussi la libération aussi de plusieurs
militants kong et ça veut dire que
l'accord il peut être en danger
alors ça fait partie des habitudes
européennes
à chaque fois qu'il ya des négociations
sur la chine ya là tous les sourds les
soutiens des droits de l'homme en europe
qui sont un peu scandalisé
donc pour calmer ces gens là on rajoute
que toujours des déclarations
européennes alors l'a fait pour les
français
maintenant toute l'europe s'y est mise
on rajoute des déclarations disant
pourquoi se préoccuper réellement des
problèmes de droits de l'homme en chine
et on arrive à signer l'accord est
ensuite bon c'est probable passage sur
les droits de l'homme et s'évanouit
samedi puis disparaissent comme louis
droz sable on sait aussi que les
relations entre la chine et les états
unis ne sont pas au beau fixe guerre
commerciale oblige et puis aussi la
pandémie mme avec pompey aussi
aujourd'hui il a avait clamé la
libération de sept journalistes comment
vous interpréter cette intervention
américaine alors les relations entre les
états unis et la chine ont beaucoup
changé depuis l'arrivée de trèbes au
pouvoir obama un discours extrêmement
dure vis-à-vis de la chine
mais obama n'a rien fait contre la chine
de manière tangible
trump est passé dans un autre style le
rapport des rapports de force avec la
chine un qu'ils l'ont amené à avoir de
réelles sanctions et une réelle
efficacité dans ses fonctions à l'heure
actuelle quand tu la campagne électorale
on s'est aperçu que le seul point est
pratiquement d'accord entre trump
hebeisen était la dureté vis-à-vis de la
chine mais les gens qui sont derrière
bayonne ce sont les gens qui étaient
derrière obama et qui était extrêmement
intéressé par de bons rapports avec la
chine 1 se plaît souvent à titre
personnel bailon en plus à des problèmes
de famille de lier avec la chine
quelquefois un peu complexe donc tout ça
ça va se mettre en place doucement il ya
un dernier vous pourrez parler d'un coup
de pied de l'âne de l'administration
trump et vis-à-vis de la chine
il faut voir si l'administration byden
va suivre si l'administration by dell va
retomber dans ce cas fleurs bahamas et à
dire
des discours et rien derrière juste
cette dernière question jean vincent
brisset cet accord ce projet d'accord
donc si notre pain est ce qu'il rentre
dans le cadre des routes de la soie que
cherche à promouvoir la chine
alors il est évident que cet accord
c'est une accorte hystériquement
réciproque de protection des
investissements aussi chinois en europe
et les terminaux de la route de la soie
nouvelles versions sont en europe aussi
bien les terminaux ferrer que les
terminaux maritimes
donc il est évident que c'est cet accord
va va intéresser directement les
investissements chinois au titre de la
route de la soie et on sait aussi que
l'image de la chine quand même et écorné
un an durant toute cette pandémie
puisque c'est de là bas qui est parti le
virus locaux vides 19
malgré tout aujourd'hui ça n'empêche pas
la chine d'avancé sur le plan de ses
partenariats qu'ils soient stratégiques
non avec l'europe par exemple alors je
pense que ce qui s'est passé avec la
gestion par la chine de bucovine 19 a
amené beaucoup de gens à sortir d'une
certaine vision angélique de la chine et
avec beaucoup plus rigoureux et plus
sérieux il à vis du regard porté sur la
chine d'un autre côté il y en a d'autres
qui se disent qu'après tout la chine a
beaucoup mieux géré que la plupart des
pays européens la l'épidémie d'e.coli 19
au niveau de desmaures et autres mais
elle a géré en utilisant des méthodes
qui sont pas acceptables les pays
occidentaux dans les pays démocratiques
et puis est ce qu'elle peut céder à la
demande de l'union européenne de libérer
cette journaliste qui a enquêté sur la
crise sanitaire
militant hong kong est pas votre ami
alors il est possible que la chine fasse
des petits gestes en autorisant
quelqu'un à émigrer
ça ne veut absolument pas dire qu'elle
va pas partir parce que cette cette
militante elle a réussi à être unis à
être iconiser à être placé au dessus et
qu'on parle mais il ya des tas d'autres
genres il faut quand même voir que c'est
une pays continue de mener son pays
d'une main de fer en envoyant beaucoup
de gens quand même en prison et les
empêchant de fonctionner normalement
quant à hong kong là il n'y a même pas
de nom qui sont mis en avant par le
dissident pour ceux-ci de d'ici là cela
lassé des gens qui seraient des boat
people qui auraient été arrêtés tout ça
ça s'accumule
mais tout ça ça ça disparaît aussi vite
on va parler un petit peu et puis ça
disparaît régulièrement et la chine
continuent à faire exactement ce qu'elle
veut à ce niveau là merci beaucoup à
vous jean vincent brisset directeur de
recherche à l'iris spécialiste de la
chine dans la nuit du 31 décembre la
paire de transition post break site
s'achèvera définitivement puisqu'un
accord entre l'union européenne et le
royaume uni a bien été trouvé son
application provisoire débutera dès le
1er janvier
demain les chefs d'état européens vont
le signer ensuite ce sera au tour du
parlement britannique de donner son aval
une formalité pour le premier ministre
anglais boris johnson
mais autrement tu beaucoup de questions
demeurent et inquiète les britanniques
écoutez le ministre michael gove qui se
veut lui rassurant pour les entreprises
nous produirons des papiers
administratifs mais malheureusement nos
clientes également une série de
documents à produire pour permettre à
l'importation de se poursuivre alors
pourquoi acheter au royaume uni autant
acheter chez un autre producteur en
france qui peut livrer à domicile
pas de papiers administratifs pas de
problème nous travaillons plus
intensément avec les entreprises afin de
nous assurer que tout le monde est prêt
pour les nouvelles opportunités et défis
qui se présenteront après le 1er janvier
je pense que les affaires sont
globalement bien engagée mais forcément
avec tous ces changements avec toute
transition il ya parfois des moments
compliqué les heurts du royaume uni au
sein de l'union européenne sont donc
comptés cependant un contentieux
territorial subsiste celui de gibraltar
la situation de l'anc la britannique
situé au sud de l'espagne n'entre pas
dans l'accord commercial trouvé entre
londres et bruxelles
est ce un terrain d'entente
d'impressionnants embouteillages de
camions de marchandises pourraient se
multiplier les travailleurs
transfrontaliers se retrouvait bien
embêté lé précision avec quentin
mauclair le retour des contrôles aux
frontières
au coeur des inquiétudes à gibraltar
lanclas britannique fait l'objet d'âpres
négociations entre le royaume uni et
l'espagne
objectif simplifier le passage entre les
deux territoires notamment pour le
transport de marchandises
la ministre des affaires étrangères
espagnol a annoncé ce lundi vouloir
conclure à un accord ce serait vraiment
dommage si gibraltar était le seul
endroit où ça pique un brésil dur dans
toute l'union européenne états mais il
n'y a pas de plan de l'est soit il y
aura un accord entre le royaume uni et
l'espagne soit il y aura une frontière
fermée
il n'y a pas de clan dsk n'a glané en
cas de nos deals de longues files
d'attentes de camions pourraient sa
massés à la frontière
les images semblables à celles des
transporteurs bloqués dans le port
anglais de douvres quelques jours avant
noël pourrait devenir quotidienne aux
abords du rocher le retour des contrôles
aux frontières aurait également des
conséquences pour les nombreux
travailleurs transfrontaliers près de
dix mille travailleurs travers cette
frontière chaque jour espérons le d'ici
le début de l'année prochaine les choses
se passeront plus facilement pour nous
les travailleurs comme vous pouvez le
voir il y à un nombre de personnes qui
franchissent la frontière ici sans
interruption c'est leur gagne pain et
nous espérons que nous ne continuerons
pas à subir les retards que nous avons
by ces derniers temps du côté espagnol
de la frontière à l'alinéa des
conceptions la possibilité d'un odile
inquiète également
si un accord n'est pas trouvé les
répercussions économiques sur la région
pourrait être dévastatrice avec un
contrôle aux frontières donc sans
fluidité de circulation des personnes et
des marchandises
je pense qu à court ou moyen terme
l'alinéa pourraient disparaître car
l'économie de la linea dépend beaucoup
de gibraltar
donc pour nous il est crucial qu'il y
ait une circulation fluide des personnes
et des marchandises à travers la
frontière
mais ce n'est pas seulement pour
l'économie c'est aussi pour la vie
sociale et familiale gibraltar se
retrouve donc sous la menace d'un bric
site duré le temps presse madrid a
accepté ce lundi d'accorder à londres un
délai de 72 heures pour formuler une
nouvelle proposition en vue d'un accord
tout en excluant la possibilité de
poursuivre les négociations en 2021
et pour en parler notre ronde john locke
landais universitaire britannique
spécialisée en géo politique et
philosophie politique
bonsoir merci d'être en direct avec nous
ce soir sur rtl france est bien d'accord
donc à in extremis
on l'a 10 entre londres et bruxelles et
que s'est il passé on a oublié gibraltar
jpreister à la différence des
départements où outre mer français ne
fait pas partie du royaume uni est donc
ce territoire n'est pas concerné par la
cour qui a été arraché comme vous
l'avait dit à la dernière minute le 24
décembre
gibraltar n'est pas à la différence de
l'irlande du nord par exemple ne fait
pas partie du royaume uni est donc ce
territoire est gouvernée par d'autres
règlements dans votre reportage vous
avez me semble-t-il confondez deux
choses très différentes
vous avez montré les images de files
d'attentes de camion près de douvres qui
se sont accumulés un peu avant noël mais
pourquoi se sont elles se sont elles
accueillent accumulé c'est que de cesser
ces files d'attentes et bien c'est parce
que la france pour des raisons
sanitaires a fermé les frontières a
fermé ses frontières vis-à-vis du
royaume-uni
or ce dont il est question maintenant
quand vous évoquez le break site du haut
ce n'est pas de fermer la frontière avec
gibraltar entre gibraltar espagne mais
de mettre une frontière dur c'est à dire
de mettre des contrôles mais ça c'est
très différent des contrôles aux
frontières
il y en a non pas partout mais il y en a
quand même en europe aujourd'hui quand
vous allez de la france royaume uni
vous devez passer par les contrôles vous
devez montrer votre passeport
à la différence de ce que vous faites si
vous aussi vous allez de la france en
allemagne
donc il y a déjà des frontières dur ce
qu'on appelle des frontières dur à des
frontières homogène local on se
rassurera le un mot sur le statut un mot
sur le statut quand même de gibraltar
pour qu'on comprenne bien puisque la
ministre des affaires étrangères
espagnol a lancé un ultimatum tout de
même au royaume uni de 72 heures pour
trouver une solution
oui mais le statut n'est pas en question
le gibraltar
est un territoire britannique depuis le
traité d'utrecht en 1713 bien sûr
l'espagne revendique la souveraineté sur
ce territoire
l'espagne n'ont jamais vraiment accepté
de traiter du traict mais je ne crois
pas sincèrement que l'espagne va faire
main basse sur gibraltar jeu à moins que
son allusion que nous avons entendu tout
à l'heure dans votre reportage à une
frontière fermée ne soient une menace
peut être que l'espagne et peut-être
madrid est en train de de menacer
gibraltar et le royaume uni alors est-ce
que des négociations est ce que des
négociations qui vont qui vont débuter
pour justement éviter que gibraltar ne
se retrouvent lésés vous l'avez double
et là tout à l'heure je n'ai pas entendu
ce qu'elle a dit en espagnol si elle est
ici la ministre a dit que la frontière
serait fermée à ce moment là il s'agit
très clairement d'une menace l'espagne
voudrait évidemment rendre la dite la
vie difficile pour gibraltar ça c'est
sûr mais les négociations bien sûr il y
en a bien sûr mais même dans le cas où
elle échouerait le fait qu'il y ait une
frontière durée des contrôles ce n'est
pas grave ce n'est pas la fin du monde
encore une fois je répète il y en a
aussi ailleurs en europe il y en avait
ans pour aller en suisse jusqu'à il ya
pas très longtemps il y en a toujours
pour aller en angleterre donc une
frontière dur ce n'est pas si grave que
cela
dans l'hypothèse où les négociations
échoueraient
ça veut dire que au niveau de l'anc la
britannique qui les impacts économiques
ne seront pas si catastrophique que cela
dit ce qu'est une vraie crainte si la
frontière est fermée la vie serait très
difficile mais encore une fois je ne
sais pas ce que la ministre a dit si
elle a parlé de fermer la frontière de
faire un blocus contre j'y parle tant ça
serait quand même extraordinaire
je ne pense pas que la traduction a été
fidèle à moins qu'elle fait des menaces
très grossière si par contre il ya des
contrôles qui seraient entre réintroduit
à la frontière cela ne me semble pas la
fin du monde
ne mélangeons pas les choses
le royaume uni qui est la cinquième
économie au monde vient de conclure un
accord avec l'union européenne qui va
réglementer 600 milliards de commerce
d'euros de commerce par an vous venez de
nous parler de l'accord avec la chine
d'accord avec la chine concerne son
milliard alors avec le royaume uni ces
600 milliards donc c'est six fois plus
important que la chine
et là vous mélangez ça avec gibraltar j
printemps c'est un village c'est trente
quatre mille personnes qui va très très
certainement survivre même dans
l'hypothèse d'un blocus espagnol sur
quoi je mets une pression il ya une
pression espagnole puisque un ultimatum
lancé donc faut bien se préoccuper aussi
de gibraltar quand même oui mais est-ce
que vous vous êtes en train de me dire
que l'espagne elle va fermer la
frontière comme franco en 1969
j'ai voté un brick site dur donc oui
mais c'est ce que je suis en train de
vous dire un préfecture ça veut dire de
la réintroduction de contrôles aux
frontières
ça ne veut pas dire la fermeture de la
frontière vous ne pouvez pas mélanger
deux choses s'il y a des contrôles safa
sans doute ralentir un peu le trafic
évidemment mais si la frontière est
fermée par contre à ce moment là cela
devient effectivement un grand problème
mais ne faut il ne faut pas mélanger
mexique duo qui est déjà une expression
un peu biaisé qui équivaut à la
réintroduction de contrôles à la
frontière
il ne faut pas mélanger cela avec la
fermeture de la frontière
ce à laquelle je ne crois pas donc pas
tannique donne le clan ben voilà pas de
panique
merci beaucoup à vous je rappelle que
vous êtes universitaire à britannique
spécialisée en géo politique et
philosophie politique et dans quelques
instants nous parlerons des dernières
annonces d'olivier ferrand le
confinement écartée pour le moment
l'extension du couvre-feu envisagée à 18
heures dans certains départements les
régions à les plus touchés et ce à
partir du 2 janvier puis nous
reviendrons sur la détresse
psychologique des commerçants
entrepreneurs ou étudiants épuisé à part
les conséquences de la pandémie siens
[Musique]
la france oubliée c'est une rencontre
avec ces citoyens qui ne se résignent
pas à la fatalité
on est comme tout le monde même si on
n'est pas en appartements ont énervé
grenelle sentiment qu'il faut à chaque
fois se battre ils vivent parfois au
bord des routes nationales pas forcément
loin de paris mais toujours moins de
ceux qui les dirigent
moi j'en ai marre qu'on y passe un tour
de tracteur et cnooc vivre en campagne
il faut savoir c'est qu'une vie
différente
ils ont le sentiment d'être des français
de seconde zone comme s'ils étaient
invisibles ma forêt td quoi peut plus
aujourd'hui la france oubliée c'est
montrer ce qu'on ne voit jamais
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
comment on peut expliquer qu'elle un
groupe énorme comme areva qui est
spécialisé puisse acheter des mines
inexploitables
ce n'est pas explicable mais ça permet
d'envoyer aussi des gratifications on va
dire à des à des politiciens nigérien la
gestion fantaisiste d'areva a des
répercussions incroyable jusqu'au
président américain obama donne son
accord pour qu'areva bénéficie d'un prêt
de 2 milliards de dollars alors que
l'agent ce qui est censé gérer ces prêts
un avis négatif
je ne suis pas pour ou contre le
nucléaire je suis simplement pour une
industrie sans corruption parce que
cette industrie là si elle crée un
incident c'est pour l'éternité
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire que notre peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez qu'au moins que dès qu'on dit il
n'y a pas d'alternative on sort du pays
il est clair que tout le monde attend
sable est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
déçu l'univers l'uniforme c'est quand
même des hommes comment ces mecs-là
arrive à dormir la nuit là aussi je
pense qu'on a vécu quelque chose
d'inusité gilet jaune c'était des
valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
les gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas de la louve
ligue parlementaire
ça se passe en direct puisque on est en
direct il y a quand même la liberté
je vous remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
vous insistez beaucoup sur l'aspect des
dépenses publiques ce que je critique
c'est que on est dans un état
d'addiction de grande dépendance à la
dépense publique je ne veux pas du sang
et des larmes leçon il est l'âme on les
a déjà trop de dépenses trop d'état je
pense en tout cas qu'il ya trop de
bureaucratie c'est à dire un état
inefficace tout ça a été financée
essentiellement par de la dette
le problème est moins la dette en
réalité moi je pense qu'on remboursera
la dette par la croissance donc il faut
essayer de libérer l'économie française
et notamment le travail
notre problème en france c'est un
problème où la dépense publique et est
excessive
mais surtout elle n'est pas productif
les français n'en ont pas pour leur
argent
de ce point de vue là emmanuel macron
n'a rien changé par exemple par rapport
à son prédécesseur françois hollande
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
quelle image
il laisse de lui diego maradona en
argentine il laisse une image bas dudok
d'une icône absolue d'un dieu vivant
parce qu'il a porté très haut les
couleurs d'un pays qui était humiliée
par la guerre des malouines ce pays a
gagné la coupe du monde alors c'est pas
une victoire militaire mais c'est une
revanche politique et sportif sur une
défaite militaire parce que la politique
et le sport font finalement bon ménage
maradona revendiquait de mélanger sport
et politique y c'était un homme dutra
gauche on connaît sa proximité avec
castro on connaît sa proximité avec hugo
chavez
il avait cette sensibilité de toujours
incarné bien les dix khamis à dos les
sans-chemise il a toujours joué dans des
clubs qui incarnait la révolte par
rapport au pouvoir central
vous êtes en pas en train de dire
finalement diego maradona c'est l'homme
du passé ce cap a un côté paradoxal le
moins que l'on puisse dire c'est que le
personnage n'est pas lisse et qu'il a de
multiples aspérités et c'est pour ça que
c'est un personnage de légende
[Musique]
bien sûr il ya des choses qui changent
bien sûr le monde change
il a d'ailleurs changé entre l'enfance
du général de gaulle et 1969
ce qui ne change pas c'est la condition
humaine et une certaine idée que la
civilisation se fait de la dignité de la
personne humaine et de sa liberté si
vous aviez deux ou trois mots pour
caractériser ce que vous appelez la
méthode l'attitude l'art de gouverner
vous diriez quoi tout d'abord
l'indépendance de la nation
ensuite la souveraineté du peuple et
enfin une conception de la france une et
indivisible
appuyez sur la fierté nationale devons
réapprendre à dire non comme disait
malraux seul l'esclave dit toujours oui
ça la réinfection dessus du bureau de
chaque responsable politique en
particulier de ceux qui se prétendent
des hommes d'état
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième heure d'information tout
de suite
voici les titres de l'actualité de ce
mardi à 29 décembre le confinement
écartée pour le moment mais une
extension du couvre-feu envisagée à 18
heures dans certains départements des
régions les plus touchées et ce à partir
du 2 janvier une annonce tout à l'heure
de l'île et veyran celle au contraire 2
france 2 les décisions seront annoncées
dans le courant de la semaine prochaine
quant à la levée de la totalité des
contraintes le 7 janvier cela paraît
difficilement concevable précise le
ministre de la santé siens aux défis
sanitaires et économiques de l'année
2021 s'ajoute celui des réformes comment
tenir le calendrier prévu par une
manière de mâcon projet de loi sur le
séparatisme convention citoyenne pour le
climat et bien sûr relance de la réforme
des retraites l'agenda parlementaire
très chargée s'annonce cruciale en vue
de la présidentielle
enfin en 2022
[Musique]
l'émotion reste vive au lendemain de
l'annoncé du décès de soldats français
dans le centre du mali trois décès qui
portent à 47 le nombre de soldats
français tués au sahel depuis 2013 dans
les opérations serval puis barkan le
premier ministre astral et son réveillon
auprès des troupes françaises au tchad
l'occasion pour jean castex d'engager
une réflexion avec le président qui à
dire idriss déby sur le maintien à des
militaires tricolores sur place la
russie la turquie vont poursuivre leur
coopération militaire une annonce du
chef de la diplomatie russe sergueï
lavrov lors d'une rencontre avec son
homologue turc à sotchi est la libye
également au coeur des discussions alors
que le maréchal rallye faf tard a appelé
les ses forces à reprendre les armes
pour chasser l'occupant turc à la france
elle appelle à la retenue champ
m
la situation à sanitaire en france
olivier véran le ministre de la santé
était sur le plateau de france 2 ce soir
il a notamment évoqué le durcissement
des mesures dans certaines régions ainsi
que la réouverture du secteur culturel
je propose en écouter un extrait ce que
nous écartons c'est l'idée du
confinement
nous ne voulons pas confiné à ce stade
hany abo finances généraliser ni un
confinement locale la caa en revanche
nous allons proposer une extension du
couvre-feu qui au lieu de démarrer à 20h
démarrera à 18h dans l'ensemble des
territoires dans lesquels cela s'avérera
nécessaire et régions signalent instant
pas la totalité de ces régions des
départements ou des métropoles de ces
régions dans lesquelles le taux
d'incidence serait au dessus du seuil d
alerte maximale et ces mesures seront
applicables à partir du 2 janvier
il durera le temps nécessaire pour
vérifier qu'il ya une stabilisation
voire une amélioration de la situation
sanitaire
mais par ailleurs permettez-moi le prêt
le premier ministre avait parlé d'une
clause de revoyure au 7 janvier avant
cette fameuse date du 7 janvier
oui voilà et bien concerne considérant
ce que je vous ai dit sur la situation
sanitaire dans notre pays
il paraît difficilement concevable à ce
stade sous réserve de l'évolution dans
les prochains jours de lever la totalité
des contraintes
nous avons besoin de voir l'effet de
noël s'il ya un effet noël il faut pour
cela au moins une semaine de recul les
faits éventuellement du nouvel an nous
espérons qu'ils il sera évidemment le
plus faible possible et donc d'ici début
janvier nous y verrons plus clair sur la
situation sanitaire mais de toute
évidence on pourra pas lever la totalité
des contraintes
il y aura peut-être des aménagements je
pense notamment un jour travaillé en
présentiel pour ceux qui le souhaitent
ou la rouverture de l'accueil d'un de
parts d'étudiants par petits groupes de
retour aussi pour le rêve musée si ce
n'est pas à moi de me prononcer les
décisions seront annoncées courant de
semaine prochaine lorsque nous aurons la
totalité des informations à date et les
perspectives restent moroses pour de
nombreux commerçants ils seront environ
un sur quatre à avoir je suit du mal à
rouvrir et à continuer l'activité selon
les mots de william koeberlé président
du conseil du commerce de france c'est
ce qu'il a déclaré sur france info
en cause le confinement du mois de
novembre un véritable coup de massue
pour bon
boutique autre indicateur inquiétant le
nombre d'appels sur le numéro vert dédié
à la détresse des chefs d'entreprise il
serait passé de 10 à 40 par jour une
crise sanitaire qui impacte la santé
mentale des français notamment chez les
jeunes ou plusieurs suicides ont été
recensés dans les établissements
scolaires les divers confinement et les
autres mesures restrictives seraient des
sources d'anxiété et de dépression un
médecin britannique évoque même une
menace similaire à celle de la seconde
guerre mondiale pour la santé mentale de
leur côté les autorités publiques disent
prendre ce problème à xiii au sérieux
forme et pour en parler justement nous
sommes avec hélène romano
psychothérapeute spécialisée dans le
psycho traumatisme
bonsoir à vous merci d'être en direct ce
soir avec nous sur arte france
quel est votre constat le constat c'est
comme vous l'avez dit d'un ak d'une
aggravation des troubles psychiques chez
toute la population avec certaines
populations cibles les jeunes les jeunes
étudiants qui voient pas vraiment leur
vie d'adulte suspendu à ce cette période
pleine d'incertitudes et puis les
commerçants qui voient leur activité
professionnelle et donc leur vie la vie
de leur famille par pareillement
suspendu aux décisions gouvernementales
donc on a véritablement une aggravation
des troubles en gamme anxieux en termes
dépressif et en terme de passage à
l'acte conduites addictives prise
d'alcool de stupéfiants et conduite
suicidaire
et vous pensez qu'on est là face à une
bombe à retardement
on est là face à une bombe à retardement
c'est un conte avait utilisé des
premiers confinement en disant que ça
risquait d'avoir un impact extrêmement
lourd dans le temps pour les générations
de tout âge avec en particulier les
jeunes générations
on a souvent tendance à s'imaginer que
les troubles ont lieu tout de suite mais
la particularité d'être ou traumatiques
et la suprématie en est confronté un
événement il ya la mort qui rogne l
angoisse de la mort il ya tous les
bouleversements ce deuil avec ses pertes
multiples par rapport au rythme habituel
et cetera on sait qu'ils trouvent ne
vont pas forcément être immédiat
certaines fois des semaines des mois des
amis plus tard quel exemple qui a été
donné par votre avis peut se passer
après la seconde guerre mondiale on a eu
des personnes
qui ont des troubles des années après la
fin de la guerre donc c'est un risque
particulièrement important pour les
générations en particulier les plus
jeunes savaient que cette crise
sanitaire malheureusement elle perdure
elle a débuté au début de cette année
anxiété dépression des primes
finalement ça augmente au fil des
semaines au fil des mois on voit une
différence importante entre le premier
confinement et deuxième le premier on
avait une date butoir d'août les gens
s'étaient mis en tête d'organiser
c'était long et pouvant c était
particulièrement violent pour certaines
familles et sert par enfant l'a vu avec
l'augmentation des pour les
maltraitances
il y avait une période limitée là c'est
extrêmement compliqué ce isolé patients
et qui n'en voit pas l'issue ils n'en
voient pas le bout et au niveau des
consultations autant lors du premier
confinement laver nos passions habite
peine mais autant là avec la deuxième
phase de confinement on a des personnes
au moins sont les appels au sol et
plateformes téléphoniques et des gens à
monsieur madame tout le monde qui
n'avait jamais eu aucun trouble
psychologique précédemment mais qui sont
épuisés psychiquement parce que le
stress ça vous épuise l'incertitude ça
vous épuisez on voit pas l'issue
on n'arrive pas se voir quand est-ce que
ça va se terminer et l'être humain a
besoin de minimum de certitudes et
devant raconté que par sécurité mais
développe plus facilement des sanctions
la france qui fait partie des plus gros
consommateurs d'antidépresseurs ça vous
dire que fut et ce n'est pas prêt de
s'arrêter
ça va pas changer alors ça pourrait
évoluer si la france se donner les
moyens de former des psychothérapeutes
de rembourser les psychothérapies
d'avoir des psychothérapeutes accessible
pour tous le traitement médicamenteux
peut aider bien évidemment mais il n'est
pas suffisant et malheureusement on en
voit les limites on a besoin en france
avoir des moyens en professionnels
formés et à ce niveau là il ya un manque
criant qui est patent dans tous les
départements
ce soit un petit peu le psychothérapeute
1 6 4 vous avez les moyens vous avez des
besoins professionnels par moyens vous
avez des psychologues mais aussi qu'ils
n'ont pas la même expérience dans ce
domaine là donc un véritable problème il
faudrait que ce soit
accessible pour push et facilement c'est
à dire qu'on n'est pas à moi avoir un
hand attendant certains centres médico
psycho pédagogique isp aux logiques
comment la dans certaines régions et les
jeunes ce qui vous inquiète
particulièrement
et je nous inquiète particulièrement en
tout cas là là là deux catégories des
bébés et tout-petits parce qu'ils vont
grandir avec donald et interactive très
particulière parce qu'ils font grandir
sans pouvoir s'ajuster au visage à cause
des masques et on s'est pas du tout les
conséquences que ça aura ça n'est jamais
arrivé dans l'histoire d'une population
donc on va le voir probablement dans le
temps est ce que ça fera des enfants met
donc sur injonction on le sait pas ça
reste une incertitude et les jeunes
adultes les jeunes étudiants qui voient
alors vie étudiante complètement mise en
suspens il y en a beaucoup qui ont pas
pu valider leur master ii s'était alors
dernière année d'études paris alors ce
que j'aime a qui peuvent pas valider
leur année d'étude par ce cas pas de
stages possibles à cause des contraintes
sanitaires
donc si une vie suspendue et où l'avenir
parce qu'on leur propose c'est quoi
c'est la terre crie bio qui brûle c'est
des problèmes écologiques c'est le
chômage
c'est des séparations passées des choses
extrêmement dure entre nous avons besoin
des adultes pour avoir un message
d'espoir et au delà du vaccin un des
messages d'espoir qu'on peut donner
c'est que le virus se soit une quand
même de mieux en mieux mais ils ont
besoin la bulle qui tiennent le choc
parce qu'ils sont seuls et un seul face
des adultes à sécuriser l'enfant et
jeunes adolescents et jeunes adultes et
particulièrement à ces que les autorités
disent prendre ce problème au sérieux
ce que c'est le cas selon vous quelles
sont vos attentes dans les discours il
ya toujours beaucoup de bonnes
intentions et dans la pratique dans la
réalité il ya eu des recrutements avec
des gens qui sont pas spécialement
formés pas forcément expérimenté ceux
qui le sont sont complètement à bout de
souffle
parce que totalement épuisé donc il ya
un véritable besoin de formation
professionnelle sur la question du
psycho et de moyens donnés à la
psychiatrie qui soient des moyens réels
et pas des moyens de campagne et de
l'enfumage communicationnel positives
comme on voit trop souvent donc on a un
réel besoin de personnel réel besoin de
personnes formées 1 qu'il s'agit pas
d'avoir de la bonne volonté pour prendre
en charge des gens qui souffrent on a vu
lors du premier prime en moi j'étais
souvent et pas mal de personnes qui
faisait des écoutes avec beaucoup de
bienveillance du coup tant qu aucune
disponibilité mais entendre des gens
pleurer toute la journée entend des gens
suicidaire opérer des crises suicidaires
d'avoir intervenir en en charge ça
nécessite d'être formé on ne met pas au
bloc opératoire des gens très bonnes
volontés pour vous opérer et ben en si
on doit avoir la même attention portée
aux victimes et en france ça n'est pas
le cas si je peux me permettre pour
fermer mais un conseil que vous
donneriez pour aider justement à
traverser cette période compliquée car
de conseil le premier restez pas seul
essayez de mettre autour de vous les
moyens de communication de relais avec
des proches
quels que soient les moyens par
téléphone par skype n'était pas seul ou
en tout cas s'évader dans sa tête c'est
aussi important en évitant de prendre
des consommations les produits qui sont
de l'évitement et qui peuvent vraiment
conduire après des troubles importants
et puis deuxième conseil c'est se
projeter ni sur des choses positives on
est toujours sorti l'humanité toujours
senti pas de crise l'asmo crise intense
mystoires nous permettent par contre
donc c'est aussi important de se
raccrocher à ça on va en sortir ça va
pas être simple mais ensemble on
s'inscrira de façon beaucoup plus forte
merci beaucoup pour tout ces conseils
hélène romano psychothérapeute
spécialisée dans le psycho traumatisme
2020 est en train de s'achever une année
particulièrement particulière pour à
emmanuel macron dans le programme
été quelque peu bouleversé par
l'inattendu crise sanitaire et qu'est ce
qui attend le chef de l'état en 2021
quels sont les enjeux auxquels il risque
d'être confronté éléments de réponse
avec estelle phare une année utile une
année de combat de relance et d'ambition
c'est la vision d' emmanuel macron pour
car si en 2020 le coc vite 19 a
contraint l'exécutif à mettre sur pause
de nombreuses réformes
pas question pour le chef de l'état de
renoncer à son agenda économique
mais emmanuel macron devra aussi tenir
compte des enjeux liés à la santé du
pays mise à mal par la crise sanitaire
nous avons encore pour plusieurs
semaines plusieurs mois un combat
sanitaire à conduire contre l'épidémie
nous aurons aussi le combat économique
conséquence directe de la crise
sanitaire notamment pour notre jeunesse
alors que les inégalités sociales déjà
présentes vont s'accroître alors parmi
les défis qui l'attendent il ya bien
évidemment la campagne de vaccination
contre le coronavirus elle a démarré le
27 décembre dernier et se poursuivra une
bonne partie de l'année à venir
sans oublier la continuité de la gestion
de la crise sanitaire avec au menu fut
la réouverture des lieux culturels des
restaurants des bars le tout en évitant
une troisième vague et en éventuel
troisième confinement au delà du défi
sanitaire emmanuel macron va devoir
faire face au calendrier des réformes
qu'il avait initialement prévue avant
l'avènement du corona virus parmi les
différents dossiers quelques ministres
l'ont déjà annoncé la réforme des
retraites est l'une de leurs priorités
pour l'année 2000 21
il ne faut pas oublier la réforme des
retraites c'est une réforme qui est
importante c'est une réforme de justice
sociale il faut que cette réforme elle
puisse être mené
mais il faut le faire dans le dialogue
social avec les partenaires sociaux
quand on aura pu surmonter l'urgence du
moment ça fait partie de notre agenda
social pour 2021 et une réforme qui a
provoqué de nombreux
elle a manifesté de l'année dernière et
qui pour certains dans l'opposition ou
dans les syndicats est aujourd'hui loin
d'être une priorité
les français n'en veulent pas et même le
medef sur le fond plutôt favorables à la
réforme juge préférable d'attendre une
relance de l'économie avant d'engager
une réforme
si effectivement on a une économie qui
est par terre parce que l'épidémie dur
parce qu'on n'arrive pas à repartir
il ne faut pas ajouter une réforme
compliquée à une situation économique
difficile
il ya trop de tensions sociales dans ce
pays ma conviction profonde c'est qu'il
n'y aura pas de réforme des retraites
sur ce quinquennat s'ajoute à l'agenda
de 2021 la loi sécurité globale avec
déjà des appels à manifester contre ce
projet à l'e3 16 et 30 janvier prochains
la loi bioéthique de son côté sera
examiné au sénat le 19 janvier prochain
sur l'adoption ne devrait pas avoir lieu
avant l'été 2021
autres sujets au menu le climat avec ce
référendum voulu par emmanuel macron
pour introduire la protection de
l'environnement dans la constitution
pour certains défenseurs de
l'environnement cette initiative vient
masquer un profond désaccord entre les
objectifs de l'exécutif et les
conclusions de la convention citoyenne
pour le climat de nombreux chantiers et
défis pour le chef de l'état qui risque
de devoir se livrer à un numéro
d'équilibriste en 2021
l'agenda des six premiers mois de
l'année à venir devrait être détaillée
lors d'un séminaire gouvernemental
coup d'envoi le 13 janvier prochain et
pour en parler nous sommes avec henri
sterdyniak économiste à l'ofce e membre
des économistes atterrés ce un bon soir
henri sterdyniak merci d'être avec nous
sur arte france d'abord le bilan que
vous faites sur le plan des réformes
pour emmanuel macron cette année
heureusement la crise sanitaire est venu
paralyser un certain nombre de réformes
d'abord comme on va le dire la réforme
des retraites ensuite la réforme de
l'assurance chômage le gouvernement a eu
d'autres préoccupations et puis
également il faut pas l'oublier
hong hao devait avoir une grande réforme
des minima sociaux avec un revenu
universel d'activités tout ça a été
balayée par la préoccupation centrale
qui était celle de la copie des puits du
choc économique qu'elle a provoqués a
balayé par la contestation
ce qui est quand même de la contestation
oui basque et le en ce qui concerne la
réforme des retraites elles se heurtent
et d'un côté bien sûr à la contestation
dans la rue
elle s'est heurtée aussi au fait que les
partenaires sociaux en particulier les
syndicats
au bout d'un certain moment refusé de
négocier le premier ministre de l'époque
edouard philippe voulait ajouter à la
réforme structurelle que portait macro
voulais rajouter le report de l'âge
ouvrant le droit à la retraite
grosso modo de 62 à 64 ans et d'un côté
ça bloquait complètement les syndicats
même la cfdt et de l'autre c'est devenu
complètement hors sujet avec la forte
hausse du chômage que on a connu du feu
du fait de la crise de l'aco vide donc
naturellement le ce projet de réforme
des retraites est aujourd'hui disons
suspendu c'est vrai que bruno le maire
il souhaite comme à mener cette réforme
atteint pour diminuer la dépense
publique la dette a explosé elle devrait
a dépassé les 110 7 % du pib à cette
année est ce qu elle doit être
poursuivie cette réforme des retraites
la particularité de la réforme des
retraites telle qu'elle était engagée
c'est que de toute façon elle ne l'avait
défait que en 2037 jusqu'à 2037
grosso modo les personnes les retraités
partait avec les règles de à l'ancien
système dont au mieux ce n'aurait pas
été avant 2037 que effectivement il
aurait pu y avoir des effets favorables
mais de toute façon ces effets étaient
extrêmement progressif puisque la
retraite puisque la réforme
rentré en activité de façon extrêmement
lente et donc on peut pas compter sur
une réforme aussi progressifs pour avoir
un impact important sur les dépenses
publiques à la seule manière qu'on
aurait pu imaginer pour effectivement
avoir un impact sur les dépenses
publiques n'était pas la grande réforme
structurelle que portait macron c'était
tout simplement comme les méthodes
classiques d'un côté d indexer les
retraites et de l'autre dire aux jambes
vous partez pas 62 vous partez à 64 ans
mais voyez maintenant si on dit on par
pas ans passant de 2 mai à 64 ans mais
sur le marché on en parle on a besoin
grosso modo d'environ 1,6 million
d'emplois supplémentaires alors que
c'est pas du tout aujourd'hui la
priorité de garder les vieux au travail
alors que la priorité c'est de trouver
de l'emploi pour les jeunes donc que la
réforme la réforme edouard philippe est
complètement hors sujet et la réforme
macron c'est beaucoup trop
l'or pour avoir un effet il faut
rappeler aussi que le gouvernement était
englué dans des négociations
sectorielles avec les régimes autonome
les avocats les médecins les
kinésithérapeutes et pharmaciens qui
chacun avaient leurs problèmes et de
l'autre côté avec les enseignants qu'il
fallait indemnisés de la réforme qui
aurait fait baisser très fortement le
niveau de leur retraite donc tout ça est
un dossier extrêmement compliqué que
visiblement le gouvernement n'a pas la
capacité à gérer aujourd'hui alors que
déjà il a d'autres problèmes que ce soit
tiens vacciner tout le monde et surtout
relancer l'économie mais alors pas vous
en parler à juste titre oscille de cette
crise sanitaire ivs affaire a donc
revoir les priorités il ya une réforme
aussi importante à la réforme de la
santé celle ci est ce qu'elle peut être
mise de côté
non la réforme de la santé
bien sûr ne peut pas être
mise de côté il va falloir un membre
donné que le gouvernement dise
clairement on change de direction
on arrête la stratégie consistant à dire
il faut diminuer les lits d'hôpitaux
il faut réduire les dépenses de santé et
on va être obligés de prolonger
d'accentuer le ségur de la santé c'est à
dire augmenter les salaires des
infirmières des aides soignantes des
médecins hospitaliers pour que le métier
deviennent plus attractifs on va être
obligés d'augmenter le nombre de lits
parce que dans les années à venir on
sera toujours sous la menace de pandémie
donc il va falloir dépenser plus pour la
santé
il faudra repenser aussi l'organisation
du système on voit très bien que le le
partage des tâches entre l'hôpital et la
médecine libérale n'est pas satisfaisant
a actuellement donc il faut le repenser
il faut donner plus de poids aux centres
de santé aux au dispensaire
il faut aussi avoir beaucoup moins
d'administratifs dans les hôpitaux et de
donner beaucoup plus de poids de pouvoir
aux médecins et au personnel soignant
tout ça c'est une réforme nécessaire
c'est pas la réforme que envisageait
macron qui était surtout une réforme
d'économies budgétaires
il ya une réforme en tout cas importante
enfin plutôt une lutte importante pour
emmanuel macron c'est la lutte pour le
climat il souhaite donc l'inscrire dans
la constitution
c'est quand même pour le coup un combat
qui est en adéquation avec les
aspirations des français alors que l' on
l'a appris que 2020 été l'année la plus
chaude jamais enregistrée en france oui
on a un problème clair c'est que d'un
côté bien sûr les gens sont cons
lorsqu'on les interroge effectivement
sont pour des mesures plus contre le
changement climatique mais ensuite il va
falloir mettre sans musique est
naturellement ça va a heurté un certain
nombre de personnes on le voit très bien
il faut taxer le carbone et on a vu que
la taxe carbone c'était très difficile à
mettre en oeuvre il faut décourager le
véhicule individuel il faut taxer
lourdement les véhicules les plus lourds
les plus polluants
il va falloir développer massivement la
rénovation urbaine c'est des dossiers
c'est des dossiers importants
c'est des dossiers qui peuvent créer de
l'emploi mais en même temps c'est des
dossiers qui vont se heurter à aux
impôts qui vont frapper en quelques
sortes le mode de vie d'un certain
nombre de personnes il faut que les gens
perdent l'habitude de prendre leur
voiture et utilise des transports en
commun ce qui nécessite bien sûr que on
développe les transports en commun mais
ce qui nécessite aussi des modifications
de mode de vie ils veulent la rénovation
des logements
il va falloir qu'un certain nombre de
propriétaires payent pour cette
rénovation de logements donc c'est un
effectivement il va falloir convaincre
la population que oui ça doit être
inscrit dans la constitution oui c'est
un enjeu important mais en même temps sa
mue en cause d'une certaine façon notre
mode de vie
il va falloir être beaucoup moins
beaucoup moins gaspilleur si on peut
dire il va falloir métro mettre en cause
certaines pratiques qui peuvent être
très agréable mais qui sont polluantes
ou qui consomment beaucoup d'énergie et
il faut que les français se préparent à
une société
disons plus sobre est nécessaire compte
tenu des contraintes écologiques merci
beaucoup henri sterdyniak économiste à
l'ofce eux membres à des économistes
atterrés champs dans quelques instants
nous parlerons des trois soldats
français tués en mission à heroes ou
mais lille opération bas
car faut-il changer de stratégie ou
rester à tout prix ce sera l'objet de
notre décryptage et puis nous évoquerons
la visite du ministre des affaires
étrangères turc à moscou pour parler
notamment de la situation en libye
restez avec nous sur un éléphant ce
[Musique]
des organes d'un flux ans de propagande
et de propagande mensongère coup d'oeil
pour usa today
[Musique]
alors gardez vous êtes mes peines
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le faire
[Applaudissements]
l'hypothèse de rendre obligatoire le
vaccin pose problème ce qui est en cause
c'est votre liberté
mais ce qui est en cause aussi c'est la
liberté des autres
et entre la liberté individuelle et la
liberté collective il faut choisir la la
gouvernance c'est compliqué la pandémie
après les gilets jaunes le terrorisme
islamique
ça fait quand même beaucoup tout ça le
fondement la politique c'est la rumeur
ont réagi à des rumeurs et plus qu'à des
réalités ça comme conséquence que la
politique est devenue un métier du
spectacle
la loi est un objet de communication
politique
trop de lois tuent la loi et les lois
inutiles q les beaunois
[Musique]
les chinois ne sont pas des guerriers
ce sont avant tout des commerçants ils
ont négocié avec quinze pays
le partenariat régional économie globale
qui crée la plus grande zone de libre
échange du monde l'annnonce de sa
signature par vidéo à nike bouleverse
les équilibres mondiaux et consacre la
perte d'influencé américaine dans cette
partie goût il est clair qu'avec cet
accord le pôle économique mondiale tant
au niveau du développement que de
l'interactivité est dorénavant
durablement installé sur le continent
asiatique avec son épicentre en jeu
rendez vous compte un espace économique
occupé par 2 milliards 200 millions
d'habitants qui représente 30% de la
production mondiale de richesse
il est triste et même inquiétant de
constater que l'europe se retrouve
aujourd'hui marginalisée par rapport à
l'air super
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il n'y a pas une façon plume pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi que des gants dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on sort du pays il
est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
déçu l'univers l'uniforme c'est quand
même des hommes comment ces mecs-là
arrive à dormir la nuit là aussi je
pense qu'on a vécu quelque chose
d'inusité gilet jaune c'était des
valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent ces
gens qui avaient envie de transmettre
quelque chose à leurs enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas un à l'oubli
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est on dirait qu'il y a quand
même la liberté
je vous remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous tes
pieds coup politique n'a jamais été
obligé de dire la vérité d idée
courageuse des mots qui comptent la
haine en soi vient de grignan au genou
gauche extrême
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview
[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue sur rt france à si
vous nous rejoignez 21h30 heure
française au mali trois soldats français
en opération ont été tuées lundi dont
ont été victimes d'une bombe artisanale
l'explosion s'est déroulée dans la zone
dite des trois frontières où se retrouve
le mali le burkina faso et le niger la
force antiterroriste française barkani
concentre à ses efforts depuis le mois
de janvier on voit cela avec l'hymne
illégaux gâche le chasseur de 1ère
classe d'orient et saka niant le
brigadier-chef cannary maury et quentin
pocher chasseur de 1ère classe lui aussi
était âgé de 23 ans 28 et 21 ans ils
étaient déployés dans le sahel depuis le
mois de novembre pour la première fois
leur mission se dérouler dans la zone
des trois frontières où se rencontrent
le mali le burkina faso et le niger
elle est considérée comme l'épicentre de
la violence dans le sahel
l'elysée a donné des détails sur
l'attaqué qui a coûté la vie aux trois
hommes leur véhicule blindé a été
atteint par un engin explosif improvisé
alors qu'il participait à une opération
dans la région de hombori le président
de la république salue avec le plus
grand respect la mémoire de ces
militaires morts pour la france dans
l'accomplissement de leur mission
emmanuel macron a rappelé la
détermination de la france à poursuivre
la lutte contre le terrorisme
de son côté la ministre des armées a
elle aussi rendu hommage aux soldats
florence parly a notamment évoqué le but
de leur mission dans le sahel
la ministre des armées s'incline devant
la mémoire de ces trois militaires morts
pour la france
il était engagé dans une zone où des
groupes terroristes attaquent les
populations civiles et menace la
stabilité régionale tout comme notre
propre sécurité
il conduisait une mission essentielle à
la lutte contre le terrorisme au sahel
une mission de fraternité d'armes dont
les progrès met progressivement le mali
en situation d'assumer sa propre
sécurité
avec ces trois décès le bilan des
soldats français tués au sahel dans le
cadre des opérations serval puis barkan
s'élève à 47 depuis 2013
il s'alourdit à 48 en comptant la mort
d'un soldat au tchad dans le cadre de
l'opération épervier et l'avenir à de
l'opération barkan pose de plus en plus
question surtout depuis la libération
par les maliens au mois d'octobre de 210
à 10 capturé par la france en ouche en
échange d'otages place à notre
décryptage avec nous inviter pour en
parler
[Musique]
et nous sommes avec le général dominique
35 ans expert en géostratégie ancien
chef de la mission militaire française
auprès de le new de l'onu et alik
tounkara sociologue directeur du centre
à des études sécuritaires et
stratégiques au sahel bonsoir à vous
merci à d'être avec nous ce soir sur
arte france alors on voit le bilan il
est très lourd 47 soldats français tués
depuis 2013
la france doit-elle se désengager du
sahel général trinquant non les
modalités doivent évoluer
elle avait évolué d'ailleurs après le
sommet de peau je rappelle que la zone
des trois frontières dans lequel a eu
lieu l'attaqué
hier et la zone sur laquelle se
concentraient les forces françaises
il y avait eu un renforcement également
avait une meilleure coordination avec
les forces du g5 celle puisqu'il y avait
un pc commun voilà les trois éléments
qui depuis un an ont amené beaucoup de
succès tactique sur le terrain
maintenant il est certain que la guerre
ne peut être gagnée que par les pays de
la région et donc la france n'est là que
pour aider au mois de février il y aura
une réunion qui fera un bilan de ce qui
s'est passé pendant cette année et des
décisions seront prises sur l'évolution
du dispositif
aussi bien le dispositif barkan
d'ailleurs que le dispositif du g5 sahel
malheureusement la guerre tue ça nous le
rappelle brutalement parfois il y a eu
47 soldats français tués pendant cette
opération
c'est un peu moins de la moitié de ce
qu'il ya eu en afghanistan est à peu
près un tiers de ce qu'il y avait eu en
yougoslavie
il faut qu'on se rappelle que la guerre
tu que c'est c'est pas le nos soldats
qui meurent remplissent leur mission
c'est un drame pour les familles c'est
un drame pour nous parce que ce sont des
frères d'armes qui meurent mais ça n'est
pas la fin des opérations pour autant
aller tounkara qu'en pensez vous en tout
cas le président emmanuel macron il a
salué la mémoire des trois militaires
décédés la rappeler quand même la
détermination de la france à poursuivre
la lutte contre le terrorisme
officiellement en tout cas ce n'est pas
question pour l'instant que se retirer
de la région est incontestablement la le
tfc à la française laisse quand même une
force indispensable
le débit d'un calme mis cap au niveau du
gema duke ou que collet d'ailleurs les à
elle de façon générale et 2002 à
aujourd'hui effectivement les reins
l'appeller beaucoup d'humilité tancé ont
succombé dans cette ligue contre cette
force est nuisible
il avait aussi mis l'accent sur ce sont
pas seulement les forces françaises
notamment etc sans les victimes des ces
forces là
le qualité dite de profonde au cou les
éléments des fautes de france du mali et
du niger mémoire est également du
burkina ont été également victimes des
camps sont là certains jeunes d'être à
frontex locales et souffre d'une absence
puis elle bouge du côté effectif de la
partie dépassant texte soit côté mali du
niger ou même au burkina dans cette
localité où ce sont des localités où qui
ont été cléments longuement déserté par
l'ul pour les sétoises et à laquelle
désertion l'institutionnel a clairement
favorisé les stations dans un premier
temps et des narcotrafiquants nous
dépasser à ces migrants quittent un
vaste réseau mais vous voulez gagner
l'occident et par ricochet on assiste à
partie dans la nuit de la venue massive
de ces coupes près du corps violent avec
nous les chances donc c'est sur l'eau
qualité audio du mal logement
allait-on car à aller à la limite on
verra le général trinquant faisait
allusion tout à l'heure avec entre des
résultats obtenus dans la région quel
est l'état des lieux justement en
matière de sécurité est ce que la
situation elle a empiré par exemple
depuis la chute de
du président malien ibrahim boubacar
keita ou pas du tout on peut pas établir
des lignes directes d'une possible
amélioration dacia suite la suite chez
des régimes des paysans qui est un peu
inquiétant mais c'est qui et c'est qu'un
spa observable conçoit côté mali côté
goupillon pompiers l'hygiène les ai
quittés il continue à gagner du terrain
61e individus des maîtresses c'était les
zones dites noires d'humanité et qui
subissaient ces différentes attaques de
la part de ces groupuscules violents
mais aujourd'hui nous assistons un
d'épuration des centres de gravité
distance et même une bonne partie
l'issue du maillot jaune glisse et les
toucher mais soit parce que les élites
et elle résiste que les différents
efforts n'ont pas permis à ces
différentes communautés assistent à ces
soulagement desquels il faut quand même
pas le commun c'est qu'ils continuent
clairement assez vite dans ces
différentes localités au lieu de rester
et me mets dans le même temps tous ces
efforts consentis à la fois par les
amener à retenir nationale est assistée
conf où les débits takkal mais dès que
les changements de gimat a provoqué
l'irritation ces questions je pense que
les n'est pas au bilan et qu'avec cet
assistant en tellement attaques
terroristes en mai - et les
configurations de ses différentes
passions exhale général train quand la
france c'est vrai elle n'est pas seule
dans la région il ya les armes et
d'ailleurs nationales des pays de cette
région il ya aussi la force européenne
takouba le g5 sel
la minus main pour le mali est-ce que sa
présence est indispensable encore une
fois et est ce que quel bilan vous
faites justement matière de coopération
entre ces différents éléments
alors le premier point qui ait sévi
qu'il faut rappeler que les armées
françaises sont présentes à la demande
des pays africains d'abord l'opération
serval à la demande du mali et puis
ensuite l'opération barkan à la demande
des cinq pays du sahel
ça a été le cas en particulier à à pau
où le président de la république
emmanuel macron a demandé aux chefs
d'état africains de réitérer leur
demande d'appui des forces françaises
donc les forces françaises sont là à la
demande des pays africains alors il est
vrai qu'il ya beaucoup de force
vous parliez de barkan bien sûr du g5
sahel de la forme la mission de
formation de l'union européenne ue 6ème
et la minus m'a tout ça ça fait beaucoup
de beaucoup de force et la coordination
n'est pas évidente
je répète qu'il y avait un gros effort
de coordination qui a été fait depuis
pau en particulier entre le g5 sahel et
la force barkan maintenant arriver une
nouvelle force qui est la force takouba
donc les forces spéciales européennes
qui vont faire un travail
d'accompagnement des pays africains et
de travail un peu ciblées et je trouve
qu'il est très important que les
européens s investissent parce que le
sujet n'est pas seulement un sujet
bilatérales entre la france et les pays
africains qui se trouve avoir été
d'anciennes colonies mais globalement
avec les européens parce que là les
batailles peuvent être gagnés par les
armées mais la guerre et la paix ne
seront gagnés que par les gouvernements
et par le développement et le
développement
c'est l'union européenne qui peut
arriver avec des moyens importants pour
permettre à ces régions qui ont vu une
explosion démographique absolument
incroyable depuis les 40 dernières
années
ne pouvant pas procurer de l'emploi et
du développement à ces populations qui
avait explosé et sa l'union européenne
peut être très utile là dedans
donc il ne s'agit pas seulement de
neutraliser
dangeard mais qu'elle est désormais bien
développé est ce qu'elle est assez utile
l'union européenne sur le plan justement
du développement économique des
partenariats écoutez l'union européenne
est un outil extrêmement puissant mais
extrêmement lent donc je vous le concède
on aurait préféré qu'elle sainte qu'elle
s'investisse directement il y a six ou
sept ans mais déjà depuis un ou deux ans
elle s'investit beaucoup plus et les
européens sont présents aussi bien dans
le soutien militaire à l'opération
barkan que dans la présence à la minus
ma que maintenant avec takouba de la
présence avec le g5 sahel ça c'est pour
le côté militaire pour le côté
économique et financier il ya de plus en
plus d'investissements qui sont faits et
je crois que ça c'est un progrès énorme
d'avoir permis à l'union européenne de
regarder vers le sud et non pas
seulement vers l'est et de s'apercevoir
que tout ceci est à nos portes et que
c'est dans notre intérêt de permettre le
développement de ces pays à l'itu carats
sur cette question justement de la
réponse qui ne doit pas être que
militaire on l'entend souvent mais on a
l'impression qu'à très peu d'actes
concrets posés
donc on va penser que les
responsabilités sont certes nécessaires
mais elles ne suffisent pas à elles
seules
et d'ailleurs il faut quand même le
rappelle avoir amorcé le volet
développement
ces différentes forces en présences fait
tuer j'allais bien l'appeler souffre
d'une réelle coordination effective
quant à la liste contre c'est que le
prêt du groupe mais s'agissant nouveau
le développement et la paix notamment
exposé pas concernés d'abord de
commencer avec haut de ses 10 ans en
termes de gouvernance si vous écoutez
quand même vu et les populations qui
vivent dans ces crânes localité si elles
ont une bonne attaque commun ces dégâts
tensions sont au nombre des états où les
actes qu il incarne sont des actes et y
sont perçus comme des prédateurs
ce sont des questions qu'il faut le dire
les fondus de la gouvernance lui même
mais dans le même temps ce qui tend à me
reprocher à les dépenses germain moment
là
line renaud c'est onéreux dans les
schémas qui ne se passa chemin ancré
dans les attentes légitimes pour le
communautaire notamment en termes clairs
les grands projets qui sont toujours
portées par l'ignorance au projet tout à
fait important mais les quelques projets
des soins ne sont pas formulées ou ne
sont pas exprimés comme bégin est pas
une communauté dans ses positions censé
soulager les souffrances vécues et hier
s'est tenu du décalage entre les besoins
satisfaits par répartis en développement
à l'audience dino le pen et les démons
réellement formulées par les
bénéficiaires et des monnaies les
gagnants ne pas y compris la phase 5
celle sous frais également 17 des
déficits d'ancrage des points de vue
entre projet parce que sur nous mêmes
face des communautés qui ont parfois des
désaccords des complicités avec ce que
vous pouvez conduire donc vouloir
combattre les tories soit ça mais je
pense cette dernière version j'ai une
dernière question générale trinquant
puisque vous évoquez le sommet de pau on
le sait il était question quand même de
faire évoluer justement là l'opération
française voire réduire peut-être cette
force déployée au sahel
jean castex qui va se rendre au tchad
pour le nouvel an le tchad on le
rappelle qui abrite le commandement de
l'opération marcano au sahel
que faut-il attendre
de cette rencontre de cette visite on
sait que la france ait beaucoup appuyé
sur le tchad un port à martin la
sécurité au sahel
oui bien sûr tout d'abord après le
sommet de peau nous sommes à un an à peu
près de là après le sommet peau et au
mois de février il y aura de nouveau une
réunion probable ans qui se tiendra dans
le sahel et qui permettra de faire un
point et de faire évoluer le dispositif
et je pense qu'il était important que le
premier ministre aille sur place se
rendent compte voir concrètement ce qui
se passe aussi bien auprès du pc barkan
qu'auprès du président deby de façon à
se faire une opinion de façon à ce que
le président macron qui connaît très
bien la situation depuis le début de son
quinquennat qui a fait sa première
visite là-bas d'ailleurs puissent aussi
compter sur un premier ministre qui
évalue la situation avec lui et qu'ils
puissent contribuer à la réflexion et
aux décisions qui vont être prises à
l'est d'ankara justement le président
tchadien idriss déby ont fait qu'il
s'est beaucoup impliqué dans la guerre
au mali côtés des soldats français en
tout cas et beaucoup de soldats
tchadiens et beaucoup de pertes aussi du
côté du tchad
qu'est-ce qu'il faut attendre de cette
visite concrètement selon vous on sait
aussi faut quand même préciser aussi que
le tchad est un pays de l'afrique
centrale et qui a une crise aussi en
centrafrique actuellement enceinte et
objectivité les armées africaines au
doigt ou chalmé mort qu'il avait fui
instant nombre de groupes lot 7 les
années partenaires jouer or l'examen pas
et dans 7 litres quand tu perds les
pauvres l'anc mais je pense concrètement
si ça nous a fait chaud ce pôle est
question dans les couloirs et c'est
quelqu'un le fait peut le faire parce
qu'ils sont proposés par la famille
cette pause est pas de même des nations
unies à travers la milice mans sont des
réponses malheureusement et qui
souffrait des questions de commandement
est ce vous régaler aujourd'hui est
d'aller c'est la manière dont les
horizons et naturellement elle ce sont
des commandements et qui sont isolées
les anglaises affecter non seulement des
coopération militaire effective et
l'affectivité doit les amener sur tous
les commandements comme les mais
malheureusement je pense que ce sont des
questions qui sont pas clairement posée
lorsque des rafales de bon niveau il est
il est est il de cette rare quand
conclure ces questionnements les
quelques mots nos logements souffre
d'avoir des éléments défensifs au bas et
nostalgique mais pas d'aussi important
il est ce moment et les gens aujourd'hui
dans les contextes il ya un que les
façons ni dans la vie ni cement et même
les françaises et africaines et ses deux
faces en présence effectivement au delà
bci musée 25 m de coopération quelques
nouveaux lits et sous un même
commandement hp et intel commandement
commun et avare qui voulait permettre
ces différentes ces personnes militaires
de tir les listes d'attenté mais nous
n'allons pas nous livrer comme en demi
teinte ne vont pas nous diviser
justement vers des victoires sont
communes et ses amis et ses sentiments
dirigent et de l'autre ses sentiments
même en des doutes quant à l'efficacité
des forces batterie ne pouvait elle mène
une importante population auquel ses
partenaires - logement et étant donné
merci beaucoup à vous ali ton kara
sociologue directeur du centre des
études sécuritaires et stratégiques
merci également à vous général dominique
trinquant expert en géostratégie ancien
chef de la mission militaire française
auprès de l'onu sion
la russie et la turquie vont poursuivre
leur coopération militaire c'est ce qu'a
annoncé le chef de la diplomatie russe
sergueï lavrov lors d'une rencontre avec
son homologue turc à sotchi
ankara a déjà acquis un système de
défense anti aérienne russes en 2017 s
400 haies les deux hommes ont aussi
évoqué la situation en libye ont fait le
point avec notre correspondant
amoussou antoine clairement les
ministres russe et turc des affaires
étrangères se sont rencontrés afin de
parler des sujets qui fâchent à savoir
les grands dossiers de géopolitique sur
lesquels les deux pays ne sont pas
d'accord mais comme souvent ils ont
néanmoins réussi à avancer concernant
par exemple la création d'un centre de
contrôle russe aux turcs dans le
haut-karabakh ils ont aussi évoqué la
libye où le ministre turc des affaires
étrangères a tenu à rappeler la position
de son pays personne n'a le droit de
dire que la turquie est obligé de
quitter la libye
les gouvernements peuvent changer mais
nous avons des liens historiques avec la
libye il approche des pays occidentaux
vis-à-vis de la libye est différente de
la nôtre nous n'y sommes pas allés pour
défendre des intérêts imaginaire nous
sommes présents là bas en vue d'une
coopération mutuellement bénéfique et la
séquence libyenne va continuer pour
sergueï lavrov avec la venue demain à
moscou de son homologue libyen la
situation en libye est très compliqué
oui dans le sud il y a eu des incidents
violents les accords de cessez-le-feu il
n'y a pas si longtemps
mais depuis la situation s'est
globalement stabilisé et les accords
signés cet été ont été dans l'ensemble
respectées cela doit être encouragé tout
doit être fait pour consolider ces
accords y compris à l'aide du soutien du
comité militaire mixte 5 5
créé par les différentes parties
prenantes le ministre russe des affaires
étrangères a tenu lui aussi à faire le
point sur la situation en libye tout en
n'oubliant pas de rappeler ce qu'il
estime être les causes du conflit à
savoir l'intervention de l'otan en 2011
on en parle tout de suite avec kader
abderrahim directeur de recherche à
alips fin
bonsoir à kader abderrahim merci d'être
en direct avec nous sur rt france les
enjeux de cette poursuite de la
coopération militaire russo turque
quelles sont elles il s'agit de trouver
des points de convergence des intérêts
communs qui peuvent exister
éventuellement entre la russie et la
turquie sur le dossier liban libye
pardon comme comme les russes et les
turcs avaient trouvé des points de
convergence sur d'autres théâtres
d'autres conflits notamment je pense à
la à la syrie aujourd'hui à un
redéploiement géostratégique à la fac
turc et russe en méditerranée et l'enjeu
est considérable
il s'agit peut-être pour ces deux
puissances nous aujourd'hui de trouver
les voies et les moyens d'être
durablement des partenaires et des
interlocuteurs des européens ce qui
jusqu'à présent étaient plutôt mal perçu
pas à bruxelles je parle quand je dis
bruxelles je parle de l'europe
évidemment et surtout qui était très mal
perçu parce que les russes comme les
turcs étaient à la perception qu'on
pouvait en avoir
du côté européen c'était plutôt celle
d'avoir affaire à des adversaires plutôt
qu'à des partenaires justement qu'est-ce
que cela dit aussi sur l'état des
relations entre la russie et la turquie
qui vous l'avez dit sont des partenaires
on l'est on les voit aussi côte à côte
en ce qui concerne certaines médiation
notamment en syrie
cad kader abderrahim entendez là kader
abderrahim là vous ouais je vais vous
demander je vous demandais qu'est ce que
cela dit justement la poursuite de cette
coopération militaire russo turque sur
l'état des relations de la relation
bilatérale parce qu'on sait que ce sont
vous l'avez dit des partenaires
notamment dans le cadre de médiations
c'est le cas en syrie oui en effet bon
alors c'est toujours extrêmement
compliqué parce qu' il peut y avoir des
convergences mais il peut y avoir aussi
des divergences et je crois que cette
rencontre à ce niveau ministériel entre
les deux chefs de la diplomatie des
diplomaties mutuaide de l'ain de la
russie et de la turquie sont faits pour
tenter d'aplanir les divergences qui
pourraient se faire jour
donc je crois qu'il s'agisse surtout
aujourd'hui de trouver les moyens de
s'installer durablement en méditerranée
de manière à être des puissances
incontournable et à être des
interlocuteurs pour l'europe qui ne
peuvent plus faire en méditerranée comme
si ces deux pays n'existait pas et donc
je crois que c'est ça la grande
nouveauté on attend on voit ou assez
bien les contours des projets turcs et
russes
et aujourd'hui on attend toujours de
voir et de comprendre éventuellement ce
que pourrait être le projet européen sur
la méditerranée alors il est comment va
réagir l'otan justement on rappelle
quand même que la turquie état membre un
pays membre de l'alliance atlantique
oui écoutez je veux pas ici tourner le
couteau dans la plaie en rappelant ce
qu'a dit emmanuel macron le président
français lui même le temps est en état
de mort cérébrale donc sans aller aussi
loin
je crois que l'otan qui a été le bras
armée occidentale pendant toute la
période de la guerre froide doit
aujourd'hui revoir sa position sur un
certain nombre de dossiers
notamment puisque c'est ce qui nous
intéresse ce soit sur la question
libyenne et la méditerranée
parce que c'est vrai que disait sergueï
lavrov il ya un instant les occidentaux
ont une lourde responsabilité dans la
situation actuelle en libye et que donc
il me semble qu'il faut aujourd'hui
trouver d'autres partenaires pour tenter
de stabiliser la situation
parce que c'est un c'est l'intérêt de
tout le monde
la libye est un pays en méditerranée
mais il est également et peut-être même
surtout avant tout un pays au maghreb et
on a durablement par l'intervention
militaire de 2011 déstabiliser le
maghreb et il faudrait lui redonner de
la stabilité et donc favorisées et sur
la libye qui étaient étaient au coeur
des échanges également de cette
rencontre vous pensez qu'on pourrait
diriger vers une nouvelle médiation avec
peut-être l'implication de la russie en
libye rapidement
écoutez il me semble qu'elle est déjà
très très impliquée je vois pas ce
qu'elle pourrait faire de plus si ce
n'est favoriser le dialogue interlibyen
et permettre d'aboutir un véritable
agenda calendrier électoral après qu'il
y est eu un compromis politique entre la
cyrénaïque et la tripolitaine sur un
agenda commun et des institutions qui
permettent enfin de redonner à la libye
toute sa légitimité dans le concert des
nations
merci beaucoup kader abderrahim je
rappelle que vous êtes directeur de
recherche à l'ibf et c'est la fin de
cette émission va se retrouver dans
quelques minutes pour faire un point
complet sur l'actualité
restez avec nous sur arte france
[Musique]
tonique à recruter dans toutes les
couches de la société sans faire de tri
des mineurs des femmes des délinquants
des criminels de droit commun tout le
monde est venu à jaca en syrie il ya
encore quelques quelques années au
moment de charlie hebdo loups du
bataclan il y avait un état islamiste
qui semblait diriger tout ça la bascule
et se fait justement en 2015 sb c'est un
peu le passage de relais d'al qaïda
l'état islamique quelque part dans notre
politique internationale il est bien
évident qu'il faut pas créer les
conditions à nouveau une terre de jihad
et de cet appel d'air justement au
recrutement l'a malheureusement fait en
syrie en irak
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins du
bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]